قال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان رئيس الاركان
هيرسي هاليفي اجرى تقييما على الوضع على
الحدود مع لبنان برفقه قاده عسكريين في
الجيش واضاف البيان ان هاليفي التقى خلال
زيارته قاده وجنود الجيش الاسرائيلي
والاحتياط واشاد بالاجراءات التي نفذتها
القوات في الجبهه الشماليه مؤكدا ان اعاده
السكان لن يتم الا حين يصبح الوضع الامني
امنا
الانذار في الجليل الاعلى كيف هو الوضع
الان نعم صفرات الانذار دوت اكثر من مره
صباح هذا اليوم في عدد من البلدات الواقعه
بالقرب من الحدود الشماليه مع لبنان لا
سما في كريات شموه سنير وا في المطله كذلك
خلال
هذه الصفارات ايضا سمعنا دويا
لانفجارات بالتزامن مع اطلاق الانذارات
وبعد ذلك بلديه كريات ش مونا اكدت سقوط
اربعه صواريخ في مناطقه قالت انها مناطق
مفتوحه ولم تتسبب باضرار او اصابات وكان
هذا هو التعليق الرسمي الوحيد على اطلاق
الصواريخ باتجاه هذه المناطق فيما
كانت صفرات الانذار ايضا قد دوت في منطقه
سنير الواقعه في اعلى اصبع الجليل بالقرب
من هضبه الجولان والحدود مع لبنان كذلك
دون الاعلان عن طبيعه هذه السفرات وال
النتائج بعد دوي سفرات الانذار فيما اذا
كان قد سمع دوي لانفجارات في تلك المنطقه
ناجمه عن اطلاق للصواريخ او عن اي اعترا
راض لصاروخ باتجاه تلك المنطقه ولكن بعد
اطلاق هذه الصواريخ قامت مدفعيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي باطلاق عده قذائف باتجاه
المناطق الواقعه داخل حدود لبنان وتكرر
اطلاق الضربات المدفعيه باتجاه تلك
المنطقه بالتزامن مع تحليق للطائرات
المسيره وكذلك الطائرات الحربيه هذا ياتي
ايضا بالتزامن مع حديث متكرر و
بدا يتسع في وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
حول واقع هذه الجبهه وال الحديث عن ايضا
علاقه حزب الله ب الصفقه المرتقبه والتي
يجري الحديث عنها وبشكل اساسي عن مدى
امكانيه اعاده السكان الى المناطق التي
خرجوا منها 21 بلده اسرائيليه على طول
الحدود الممتده مع لبنان تم اخلاءها اكثر
من 70 ال اسرائيلي تم اخلاؤه من المنطقه
وكان هناك حديث واضح من قبل رئيس الاركان
هرسي هاليفي الذي قام بزياره المنطقه بانه
لن يتم اعاده السكان الى المنطقه دون
التوصل الى تحقيق الامن في هذه المنطقه
شكرا لك حسن مسعود مراس جزيره كنت معنا من
الجليل الاعلى